hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the catalase test so before we
start talking about the procedure for
the catalase tests talk about what
catalase is it is a pretty common enzyme
remember an enzyme is a biological
catalyst something that catalyzes a
reaction helps speed it up so it's an
enzyme in either aerobic organisms or a
really any organism that lives in an
oxygen-rich environment and that's
really the key
so even facultative anaerobes those that
carry out anaerobic respiration who
don't necessarily use oxygen but but
sometimes do so they can be anaerobic or
aerobic but any organism is living in an
oxygen-rich environment probably is
going to need to have catalase because
catalase catalyzes a really important
reaction to break down byproducts of
oxygen metabolism so what catalase does
is it catalyzes a reaction where it
breaks down hydrogen peroxide so break
down hydrogen peroxide into two products
water and oxygen gas and this is
important because it protects cells from
oxidative damage that comes from
reactive oxygen zzs
so reactive oxygen species sometimes
abbreviated as ro s these refer to
things like hydrogen peroxide superoxide
anything that's not like a an oxygen
free radical like a hydroxyl free
radical because these can cause a lot of
oxidative damage to cells that can
damage proteins and even more
importantly they can damage DNA so it's
important that we eliminate that we
reduce that damage in cells that live in
these oxygen-rich environments and all
of these reactive oxygen species are
natural byproducts of normal oxygen
metabolism and so catalase is the enzyme
that specifically is taking care of the
hydrogen peroxide portion of that of
those I products so the catalase test
which is our main focus today is
actually a diagnostic tool so used in
laboratories used in hospitals to help
distinguish or differentiate between
different types of bacteria that might
otherwise look the same under a
microscope so for example Staphylococcus
I which are gram positive are catalase
positive this means they produce
catalase on the other hand streptococcus
I and enteric oxide which are also gram
positive our catalase negative
so Staphylococcus I struck to [ __ ] sign
and tarik oxide they're all [ __ ] signing
that they're the round and they're all
gram positive which means that they can
be difficult to distinguish even with
cement and gram stain but they can be
distinguished with this catalase test
also bacillus and Clostridium species
again both gram positive both rods and
they can be distinguished with a
catalase test because bacillus species
are typically catalase positive while
Clostridium species are typically
catalase negative and so now let's talk
about the catalase test itself two
really critical factors for the catalase
test that make it such a great
diagnostic tool is the fact that the
procedure for the catalase test is
really fast and also really cheap so
that just makes it really easy and
convenient to carry out and this is what
you do you mix one or sometimes more
than one depending on the size of the
colony one or a few colonies from a
culture that's been growing for about
eighteen to twenty-four hours into a few
drops of 3% hydrogen peroxide on a slide
and so here we have a slide here we have
a you know a few drops of hydrogen
peroxide here's a few drops of hydrogen
peroxide if you have rapid formation of
a large amount of bubbles that means
that you have a catalase positive
organism so if a catalase negative
organism is added to the hydrogen
peroxide you won't see any bubbles form
or if there are any bubbles they'll be
they'll form slowly and it'll be a very
weak reaction whereas if it's a cat
these positive organism is being added
to the hydrogen peroxide you're going to
see really rapid formation of lots and
lots of bubbles you might be asking
yourself where these bubbles coming from
and it's this right here so this oxygen
that is a product of this reaction that
catalase catalyzes the stoppage in is in
gas and so it's given off in the form of
gas which causes the bubbles to form and
there's a couple of things to keep in
mind if you're doing a catalase test one
is that you can't use cultures that have
been grown on blood agar but because
blood auger actually is a bacterial
growth medium the contains red blood
cells red blood cells themselves have
catalase and so when you collect the
colonies from blood auger you're going
to also be collecting red blood cells
which have catalase in them and can give
you a false positive the other thing to
keep in mind is if you're testing some
of these anaerobic cultures you might
use 15% hydrogen peroxide and that just
is going to help to give sort of a
stronger more easily observable reaction
and then also if you have slow weak
bubble formation meaning bubbles that
are forming just a couple at a time it
might take a few minutes for them to
show up that's actually due to light
exposure I think we've all seen hydrogen
peroxide at the grocery store and it
comes in that brown bottle and that's
because hydrogen peroxide itself will
break down into water and oxygen gas
just due to the presence of light
although that's much much slower than
catalase catalase is actually one of the
fastest enzymes I had one of the fastest
turnover rates of all known enzymes and
so light can catalyze this reaction but
is much much slower and so if you have a
slide sitting out for a few minutes and
you're getting a few bubbles that's due
to light exposure not to be confused
with the presence of catalase so that's
it for today if you're interested
and learning more about different
bacterial species oxygen needs you can
see my video on bacterial oxygen
preferences if you're injured in
learning more about enzymes you can see
my video on introduction to enzymes but
that's it for today thanks for watching
biology professor